I just want to start with how much I
loved the movie and uh you know I just
want to uh say congrats it's awesome and
I'm done I'll see you guys later yeah
exactly thanks take care bye-bye so
jumping into why I get uh speaking
specifically uh Julie I want to start
with you first which is um what was your
reaction when you saw you'd be doing a
lot of walk-in talks in New York City
but in some of the scenes you'd have ice
cream because that's not one take
um my reaction was get me a spit bucket
or give it a Nicole she'll eat anything
I know there's an enormous amount of
eating in this movie which I didn't
honestly realize until we were at
Sundance and we saw it and and I was
like wow it's endless eating but she
gained like 10 pounds
no I didn't but I did but um I as an
actor I like having the business of
eating in the scene because I think it's
a it's a great sort of prop also no one
eats in films anymore
yeah yeah you want to see mouths yeah
yeah totally which is ironic because I
have a misophonia problem right yes you
did like watching people no it's the
sound sound it's the sound of eating and
so I had to cut all their disgusting
noises out is that true yes absolutely
true
um devastating the woman is she's nuts
I think it's people that um uh this and
I Nicole you're a great writer and Larry
David is a great writer and maybe both
have a little bit of uh you know some
screws that are not all together Titans
I'm in good company if you think that
very good company thank you one of the
things though about filming in New York
City I'm so curious
um do the people actually care anymore
when you're filming a movie or do they
sort of just say get the F out of here
let me explain to you something the
scene outside Paragon when I'm vomiting
on the street we had somebody walk
through that shot and give us the finger
in Los Angeles they just honk while
they're driving by they get a kick out
of room to take yeah
um uh yeah but New York it's tough it's
tough for her both of them yeah
no but in paparazzi-wise that's harder
for you guys for sure yeah yeah I deal
with it every day it's terrible you know
following me to Starbucks and the
supermarket it's awful well you're
fascinating
Nicole I listen I love your writing and
I'm just curious when for a project like
this how long from when you start
thinking about the idea until you
actually having a completed screenplay
uh I wish I remembered exactly because I
have Stacks and stacks of versions of
this script but
I don't know a year maybe but maybe two
years prior
trying to nail something down by writing
other things but once I could nail this
down you know a year and then we shot it
exactly a year ago so that's pretty
quick
timeline for me at least it is yeah also
for movies in general that's very fast
yeah so one once you once you guys
started doing rehearsals you're reading
the script I'm just curious like how
does it actually change and how precious
is Nicole with like every comma when
you're on set she's not precious with
punctuation at all or really the the
actual language in in the script but
it's not like we go and throw out the
script and start from scratch we are
working with uh very a very finely tuned
script but Nicole is collaborative so if
we have thoughts about tweaking
something here or adding this joke here
she's all ears
um and so it it has a very organic uh
feeling in the moment there's probably
not a scene that hasn't been ad-libbed a
little yeah or fussed with but
your turn but they're really the only
disgrace notes I mean really well you
are sticking to you know Nicole's
writing because it doesn't need to be
changed very much
but there's some really funny ad-libs in
there uh yeah I I laughed a lot watching
this um and also related completely
because and I think the reason why so
many people are are all in on this movie
is that everybody lies to the people you
love you know it's one of those things
so um I think it's a universal truth
that we all you know what I mean yeah
maybe that's not what you do
oh without a doubt how much are you guys
listen all three of you are very
talented and most people love your work
but how much are you sort of like uh
like Beth a little bit in terms of a
little bit of criticism can you know uh
end you I'm pretty sensitive yeah I
didn't like criticism
um
I
I I'm more of a self-criticizer to tell
you the truth so if I don't like
something that I've done it's hard for
me to let that go
um if somebody else is criticizing me
yeah I mean it's not pleasant you know
if I get a bad review or somebody says
something nasty yeah that can be very
hurtful but if I don't like something
I've done uh I I'm like a dog with a
bone on that one it's very hard for me
to let it go it's not that is not a good
feeling right
me too I mean
watching my films over the years you
know I I'm definitely a self-criticizer
why did I make that choice why did I do
this yeah you know and it's too late on
film nobody's gonna let you open it up
once it's done but yeah I'm I'm pretty
sensitive for all three of you when you
saw the shooting schedule and you're
looking at everything you have to do
what was the day you had circled in
terms of either super excited to film it
or a little bit nervous to do the scene
day one
day one was difficult because it was the
the moment in the film
went to Paragon
uh she overhears her husband and then
the vomiting and the ETC that was day
one so I was
uh I was uh very nervous about that very
nervous and it couldn't be helped I mean
yeah actors came to me and it was like
uh I what the you can bleep me if
you have to uh more like yeah you made a
face they were more like can this be
changed does this really have to be our
first day right and for a variety of
reasons it did and I think we were all a
little anxious about it and the fact
that it turned out as well as it did as
a tribute to professionals
but it was it was I just remember
thinking we hadn't had any time to even
get to know each other personally yeah
yeah and all of a sudden we're
pretending yeah I know it was wild
that's what good actors do I think my
day was the scene the lunch where
um
where Beth
um so ounce what's happened the birthday
dinner yeah the birthday dinner sorry
the birthday dinner yeah yeah I think
they had that a bit circled it that's
true so interesting I spoke to Donald
Sutherland once and uh or maybe more
than once and he said that he always
demands the first few days of filming or
from the middle of the movie because
that way no one will by then people just
buy into what he's selling and um you
know it's just the middle of the movie
it's not the beginning or the end it was
interesting that is interesting well you
know schedules are a mess and so we kind
of did maybe not quite the middle but
somewhere in there end of First Act yeah
but Nicole before I run out of time with
you I loved your episode of
extrapolations and I just wanted it's
fantastic it's one of the best of that
series uh can you and I know I'm just
about out of time but um because I want
to shine a light on that as well can you
sort of talk about working on that
series and the importance of that series
well I I jumped into the series for
obvious reasons it's you know know I
think it's hard to um turn disaster and
impending doom into
um something watchable and I think that
Scott Burns created a show that was that
made us able to watch this and also be
entertained and
um
uh so I was really happy to do it and
obviously I worked with some amazing
actors it was a great opportunity yeah
for anyone who hasn't seen if you
haven't watched extrapolations yet I
absolutely recommend it fantastic series
on Apple TV thank you on that note gotta
go um congrats on the movie for real
loved it I wish you guys nothing but the
best thank you so much